[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and uh wyatt russell set to join us he
comes from
hollywood royalty his dad uh the great
actor kurt russell
and his mom is uh goldie han and uh why
joins us
do you like do you feel like a superhero
you tell me do i look like a superhero
no you don't in disguise this is my
this is my lighting setup dan this is my
ring light
wow it's very professional very
professional
i'm the only person to ever actually
have marvel take money from me after the
movie
uh how did this happen wyatt you're
you're captain america
yeah it was i i don't know i i
they called and said like hey come in
and read for a person and then
for like a marvel character they don't
tell you who you're going to read for
and then you do it
and they're like great you're the guy
and then and then it's like
thank you who's the guy
who am i gonna who am i gonna play and
then they tell you and first it was like
i don't know
you know it's like chris evans is the
man and he did the
i don't want to do that they're like oh
no it's not really that then they
explained to me what the character was
and so um after they explained it i was
like okay that could be that could be
pretty cool
but how do you act like a superhero in
the audition
i i i didn't because they do a good job
of making like
it's not you're not a suit it would be
amazing if they gave you a suit and said
okay now
i do your best to fly around the room
and and uh
that would be incredible but they just
they just give you like a scene that
to to act in and then they decide
whether or not
you're going to be a superhero or not
also just regular dialogue
yeah this is regular dialogue like it's
not it's really nothing there was no
special circumstance to how they decide
whether who is going to be the guy or
not
but how how much did you know about what
chris evans had done as captain america
i didn't know it other than what i other
than what not living under a rock you
know
um that like you know it's huge and
everybody loves it
and the interesting thing that i've said
a lot and i think maybe some people can
relate is i i didn't grow up
loving comic books my superheroes were
athletes it was like joe sackett
and peter forsberg and sergey fedoroff
and march
they were like superheroes you know that
those were my superheroes bo jackson was
a
superhero dion sanders was a superhero
and so i didn't ever i didn't connect
to comic books in any way and you know
say what you want about it but i just
did not
and so when it came around to doing it i
only knew marvel from the movies i
i didn't know them from the comics that
much i you know
they're always just funny guys and
tights and shields and then when i saw
the movies it was like oh they're doing
a great job of making it
you know cool and more relatable so i
just didn't know that much about it and
then you google stuff and it's like
don't do that because you'll
go down a rabbit hole you'll never come
out of it but we liken it to
taking over for tom brady like you're
you're
you're taking over for chris evans
you're taking over for tom brady no
pressure
whatsoever right and and i feel i feel
terrible for whoever has to take over
for tom brady you know it's like oh my
god good luck
you're going to fail and and so that's
was part of the part of the trepidation
and then when they told me what the
character was it was like oh okay
there's an interesting aspect that i
can't give away that um
you know is it does you do liking it to
that he created the
mcu or helped it with all those guys and
so when you're coming in you're going i
hope i can just do the thing that i do
and then but you guys know me from even
coming in last time it's like i'm the
last person in the world who thought i
would be doing this this is
not what i thought i'd be doing but here
i am but when did you
embrace acting be i mean obviously with
your parents
you know being famous but at what point
because you were
you're a hockey player did you all of a
sudden go okay
i'll give in i'll be an actor now um
when i basically when i got
basically when i got hurt to be honest
is i had done
little stuff for friends here and there
i i had done a movie and
eat a small part of the movie an agent
my agent my current
agent saw it and said is that guy
represented by anybody he called me
this is when i was playing hockey in
germany and he said
are you do you want representation do
you want to be in movies i was like well
that's not what i do
really but maybe commercials that's not
that's not what i do but
okay nice to meet you see you later take
have a nice life
and then when i got hurt it was like
well what am i going to do am i going to
coach or am i going what am i going to
do so i spent a few months off and then
came back
and called him and said look i might
want to want to do this but
um i'll give it a shot and i guess when
it really happened i was 20 years old i
got hurt
they thought i broke my neck it was a
disastrous story i'm in a hospital for
for overnight and they took a you know
scan on my neck it was a bad
bad night and um and during that night
to be honest it was like well maybe i
won't play hockey forever it was that
first sort of
you know every athlete i think when they
get real hurt for the first time
you have that thought of um this could
be over like that
you know it's not it's not forever so
that was when i first sort of
started entering my mind was i can
remember the night
who was more apt to give you advice your
mom or your dad on acting
uh no one gave me advice you know it's
like
no one gave me a it it's really
difficult to give advice for acting i
feel like because it's so subjective
it's not like a
it's not it's if your dad was peyton
manning and you're a quarterback
right and that's kind of a get in
certain ways what it's like
you you're not it's very difficult to
give that
child some form of like here's how i did
it because you're different
you're a different person you're not
going to give the the
you're not going to give the same advice
to everybody and everybody's different
so the advice was always
pretty easy it was like if you think you
can be good in a movie
and you think that you can make the
movie better then do it it's just like a
sports team and then then
make the team better if you can't then
don't do it
you know don't bring the don't bring the
team down he's uh wyatt russell he plays
john walker
the newly christened captain america
it's marvel and disney's the falcon and
the winter
soldier i got all that right right oh
yeah yeah that was
you're telling man uh how good do you
think your dad was
in miracle he
i how good do i think my dad was a
miracle i i think
he i think he should have been nominated
for an academy award
it when you have the grandkids of it's a
disney movie and it's all that so it's
not going to get that kind of thing but
if
if you have the grandkids of her brook
saying look granddad
on the screen you've done something
right
and and he and he had said before he
said before that
he real his father died my grandfather
died while he was showing that movie
and to give you an idea of what my dad
liked what my dad's like and sort of
what you know verb like uh when he
passed away it was like oh
we're gonna shut down filming and my dad
was like no i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna give me five minutes
i'm gonna skate around and we're gonna
continue doing it because that's what we
do
we go to work when you work and uh and
so
he realized in that moment that he's
like wow i'm playing my gran i'm playing
my father
and he was playing as he was playing his
dad so
he connected to herb on many different
levels and when i watched that movie
it's i i i look at it as one of the
better
you know biopic performances i've seen
in a while
did you want a cameo in that movie did
you ask for one since it was a hockey
movie
no i would they they wanted me to
and i because i was playing hockey in
vancouver so there was times where
they were like why don't you come out
and and do some of this stuff and i was
like
that was the last thing in the world you
wanted to do is we had a couple players
leave the team
to go be in the movie because they could
make money and
and it was it was like then they'd cut
then they came back and wanted to play
and it was like
sorry you're you're you're out
you made your choice dude
you decided to be an actor instead of a
hockey player yeah
yeah um mclovin has a question for you
because he said look i'm going to
be able to speak to wyatt on a different
level than you will
okay uh so he's our marvel guy and he
said that he could nerd out with you so
mclovin your question for why
no no you're gonna know so much more
than me it's gonna be it's not gonna be
a fun conversation okay
yeah i know what you're doing here don't
don't play it down
okay are you currently or have you
ever been a member of hydra i'm talking
about your character here
well these are all questions that first
of all i i
don't know and sec it's easier for me to
not know to say
i don't know because i can't say it
anyway right i knew you could
and then the two men outside my window
will drag me off and you'll never see me
again
what does that mean mclovin oh see
that's the thing why i don't work with
marvel guys so
hydra is this criminal organization that
has been against captain america for
many many many years and they sort of
are looming in the background of the
first two episodes which are awesome by
the way
yeah yeah yeah it's it's everyone says
it's been great i haven't seen him i'm
like to
find it impossible to watch myself in
that suit so i don't i
haven't watched it but i take it from
other people's friends thank you for
from other people's mouths that they're
liking it so that's yeah but get used to
this wyatt this is what you're gonna
face
when you go out for coffee and then you
know the paparazzi is going to be there
at starbucks when you come out
no one knows who i am it's fantastic no
one
it's unbelievable i think that when i
walk around and i look like this no one
does any clue
it looks like you're trying to be ryan
fitzpatrick the uh quarterback
right yeah by the way like
i'd much rather be mistaken for ryan
fitzpatrick than for captain america
have you worn the outfit home for your
wife
yeah i i i'm sure she would maybe ask
for a divorce if i were at home shoot my
my the question there'd be too many
questions to answer as to why i was
doing it
i have a legitimate question okay okay
so
i i want to know how
to the penny how much was
the fritzy cone of shame how much did it
cost to install that thing because it
has a beautiful
rate of descent when it goes
do you mean this curtain that's going
down on fritzy right really gonna do
this to me
yeah yes i can't i can't see it
but it just seems like it must have been
like 12 grand
it must have been something expensive
i truly don't know how much it cost i do
know that
the guy who was installing it couldn't
understand
why i wanted it and i just said this is
what i want it's a cone of silence
and i think the velvet was the expensive
part of this all of the
fabric that i made for pritzy's cone of
silence but but thank you for
above all the questions you could ask
wyatt thank you for uh for asking that
question
it's it's great to talk to you and uh
good luck with the baby and the family
thank you so much take care guys that's
wyatt russell